mais libre à tête avec vous
oui
et
en prévision et je l'espère et je le
sais un nouveau carton j'attends ce film
depuis très longtemps que ça fait très
longtemps que j'en avais parlé tu avais
parlé du pitch et ça y est il est arrivé
on va voir tout de suite la
bande-annonce super héros malgré lui
encore une fois fifi tarek et julien c
voilà c'est tout ce que j'aime je vous
dis c'est que tu le sais je me repasse
vos films on boucle non mais vraiment
j'ai en fait je vous dis et je vous jure
que c'est vrai je ne regarde même que
vos films à part les vieilles vignes
genre voilà les et bronzés ou et voilà
où voilà sinon je ne regarde que vous
non mais vraiment je vous le jure que
c'est vrai peut demander à mes potes je
ne regarde que vos films j'ai la chance
d'avoir une petite télé
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est à dire
que pendant les vacances je n'ai regardé
que mon fils mais je n'ai revu comme au
film voilà donc voilà donc encore mieux
que je vais voir encore onze fois donc
voilà les gens me disent mais t'es pas
bonne ou encore tu regardes un vieux oui
tu ne regarde que ça voilà c'est tout et
voilà et je sais que voilà bravo parce
que je vous aime parce que vous êtes
voilà vous faites votre truc où ils ont
ils n'ont pas du tout pris la grosse
tête parce que c'est les mecs les plus
bankable du cinéma français mais faut
pas l'oublier mais c'est vrai et à
chaque fois c'est un beau
but
et
puis je m'en moque j'ai remué baby
sitting j'ai vu tout rouge et j'ai fait
que ça voilà je vous le dis donc voilà
je t'aime est une formidable série
c'est très gentil non mais vraiment
pourquoi tu es continent mais je vous
jure c'est un truc de fou j'ai jory je
ne je ne ris pas autant c'est vous qui
êtes les mecs qui me font que plus rien
voilà je vous dis c'est à chaque fois
que je regarde je dis [ __ ] me prenez
pas pensé à faire ça c'est tellement
drôle je pense qu'on peut arrêter
l'émission là dessus non mais vraiment
je vois la chose dit je suis hyper fan
en plus vous êtes des potes et je dis
souvent julien aussi est ce que c'est
vrai que tarek et fils et voilà c'est et
julien c'est un comédien exceptionnel je
vais bien tu as un truc vraiment il me
fait rire tout ce qu'il fait c'est juste
voilà je veux dire c'est bon c'est
fait
on aime beaucoup et si cette émission on
aimait mieux la télé souvent par contre
les tables ont rétréci la wii
je ne cache pas qu'on est pas super bien
sur le budget
je crois qu'on a tous pris pour les to
du devis aux attentes non mais c'est
parce que voulez vous remettre les trois
côtés alors on a internet on a très
rarement trois invités banques ont eu
trois invités y en a un qui
[Musique]
non mais ça non mais on a rarement 3
d'invités et on voulait vraiment vous
avoir tous les trois mois je vous dirais
des on voulait pas couper 2 3 voix si on
reviendra ici et puis à côté de
guillaume gentil on a peur des maladies
cette meule à côté de matthieu delormeau
sava mathieu pas monsieur moi un autre
on va voir la bande-annonce
façon je n'ai même pas besoin que je dis
franchement je n'ai même pas besoin de
faire de promo c'est que ça va cartonner
et donc vous venez aussi parce que c'est
mes potes j'avais envie de les voir
aujourd'hui 2 qui fait un peu avec eux
mais c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois que
vous sortez un film c'est un événement
et tout le monde de tourner avec vous je
le vois moi qui chaque fois je vois un
make you christian qui est un pote
question clavier gérard jugnot tout et
tout le monde veut tourner didier
bourdon tout le monde à qui fait-on
égouts et tout le monde veut tourner
avec vous et franchement c'est ça me
fait plaisir voilà je suis heureux à
chaque fois que vous cartonnez et
j'étais j'attends vraiment que ce film
va encore avec un carton chez nous ouais
mais j'ai adoré mais non mais moi je
suis fan même pas faire n'importe quoi
je rigole maintenant aller demain alors
après
sa passe à punta cana que l'on accuse un
x s pour raymond c'est parce que je
m'appelle cédric huit comédiens il fait
une passe et le casting du redonnet
bad man c'est moi
le premier super héros
français bref tout allait au mieux
jusqu'à cette fameuse nuit
où j'ai perdu la mémoire
c'est pas
je crois que mon frère se prend pour le
personnage de son film de super héros
ont rattrapé avant qu'il fasse une
connerie clos
[Musique]
n'en parlons plus
je
[Musique]
ça sort demain super héros malgré lui
encore acquis qu'est ce que ça fait du
bien franchement mehdi ben barka comme
ça j'en demande voilà c'est ça que je
veux pas que ça rigolait si vraiment
c'est du rire je suis moi je rigole tout
seul c'est ça c'est rare quand il sonne
comme un art mode ouais c'est une gueule
vraiment c'est ça s'accepte géraldine
touati en plus au terminal et les films
un peu intello qua non et ça j'adore me
marrer mais non je sais pas mais moi
mais mes enfants connaissent toutes les
toutes les répliques de tous leurs films
parker dans mon os x et ils vont adorer
celui-là c'est une parodie super réussi
complètement déjanté c'est enfin c'est
vraiment très méchant c'est ça que
j'aime et que c'est méchant et si on
n'arrête pas dire qu'on veut pas rire de
tout mais vous dans vos films vous
rigolez de tout et vous hésitez pas
assez trash c'est juste génial quand on
adore les ratés vous êtes tellement un
énorme marché nous est tellement
d'électro
he a cassé mais c'est extraordinaire
tareg vous êtes géniaux et je dois dire
que elodie fontan quai dans le film les
jeunes et un contre-emploi aussi elle
pousse de la fonte et elle est aussi
génial tout ça devrait commencer à être
ici c'est incroyable vraiment et à
chaque fois ça c'est à chaque fois c'est
bien vu
surtout longtemps que tulle en tête ce
truc ouais j'ai eu l'idée il ya très
longtemps c'est en voyant le film la
mémoire dans la peau noyade est un petit
peu de design gammon qui nous regardent
on
me dit que c'est matt darmon qui nous
regardent la synagogue détournait lula
est donc pris et je me suis dit voilà
qui avait un sujet enfin la perte de
mémoire je pensais qu'il y avait un
sujet battant commettiez voilà c'est
comme ça qu'elle lui est venue l'idée
oui battu oui je n'ai pas pu voir le
film iron man mais j'aurai alors que
vraiment tarek est de plus en plus beau
vraiment chaque fiche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
obligeant à des gens comme alors moi tu
ne t'arrêtes tu sais que voilà je
devrais je pas tous par laquelle moi oui
directement
tarek vraiment tu es magnifique album on
est tous les trois
magnifiques à paris et fifi qui s'est
mis au pas de hold up paddle il s'aliène
paddle alors je suis pas loin de te
lancer un défi ah oui pas loin c'est
combien d'années
[Rires]
je sais qui t'entourent très bien ouais
bah oui bah oui mais les gens aussi son
retour très bien quand ils sont avec moi
alors que ça je voudrais revenir là
dessus quand on parle de ça mais je
voudrais dire les gars parce que j'ai
gagné deux fois un tournoi de suite
voilà tu as un gros tournoi tu joues
avec un mec qui joue très bien que
s'appelle dimitri sachez qu'il a refilé
tournoi derrière il n'a plus gagné le
tournoi après donc les mecs voilà moi
non plus
n'a pas gagné entre les deux on n'a pas
gagné quand on est ensemble on a gagné
et quand on était ensemble n'a pas gagné
voilà donc à vous de tirer des
conclusions
d'où le fait d'avoir des bons
partenaires et d'avoir la chaudronne
c'est comme l'amour ah oui les sens ça
se fait à deux c'est vrai c'est
complémentaire oui tu vois c'est beau
j'ai rien dit bolt est dit que de la
merde là je vois là revenons sur le film
mais c'est quoi si un jour on gagnera un
tournant sont je le dis voilà on va
gagner un tournoi ensemble sur deux
panels oui bah oui
je te le dis je le sens il joue aussi
tanor moi j'ai pas encore commencé et
julien annoncé j'ai commencé à y est et
ben voilà bah non plus mais je
suis un peu partout de la tyne
faty tout bon non mais c'est quoi les
réactions dre sur les avant-premières ça
va être la folie non ccg ans et j'ai en
fait on l'a commencée depuis mi-novembre
de qu'on a dû faire et je passe 110
avant première depuis le début hier
n'était au grand rex tu es incroyable
mais gens étaient debout faste et si je
sais je sais c'est la souris fou mais
non mais ce qu'on s'envoie voilà en fait
ce que je sens c'est que à cette année
jean besoin on sait ce qu'il nous dit
souvent ils ont envie de légèreté en
fait c'est ça rires je te jure est
immense au moins très sûr que vous allez
faire une comédie évidemment il y en a
bien sûr plus sûr que c'est un truc que
vous avez fait eric je sens au tarif le
sang je me sens malade
mais le truc qui a je vous jure que
c'est ça qui me suis je les connais
depuis des années et les gars c'est un
truc de fou parce qu'ils ont toujours
l'air timide ils sont c'est à dire que
vous êtes une unité incroyable jeu
toujours c'est fou vraiment comment on
fait pour garder ses règles pour rester
comme ça aussi humble pour pas vous la
raconter futur que c'est un truc de fou
parce que cette fois on me demande ils
sont comment le 10 mai en fait c'est
vrai tu vas libre et moi il parle à tout
le monde ils sont coulissants c'est un
truc de fou dirait vraiment que fait
votre truc dans votre coin et vous voilà
vous ne savez pas ce qui se passe autour
et c est l expression qui est connu un
souhaite toujours gentil avec les gens
que tu croises en montant actuel est
recroisera en descendant du toit de leur
mauvaise
humeur et qui descendra et que je
montrais ouais
je pense que si je descends si je
descende sous sol je serai au troisième
sous-sol
non t'inquiète pas on montera ensemble
on descendra ensemble ok pourquoi
décembre non mais avec lui on est obligé
de descendre les méga au
petit vous mettre en exergue mais c'est
pas moi c'est vous qui me parlait une
somme de leurs mots qui descend j'ai pas
mis ses vrais bas je pensais à vous j'ai
attendu décembre anthony descente j'ai
pensé
alors les dialogues sont irrésistibles
le rythme est trépidant et moi ya deux
choses qui m'ont passionné parfois on
dit à des personnages secondaires qui
joue bien mais là tous les personnages
secondaires sont essentiels chaque scène
est d'anthologie chacun et camper et
fait avancer l intrigue parce que le
scénario c'est un comédie mais le
scénario on est de bout en bout
passionné c'est vrai et puis à ghazir
c'est pas une succession de sketches
exactement le scénario et un dos tres
bien ficelé et ya autre chose c'est les
scènes d'action heureux je sais que
voulait travailler particulièrement mais
là c'est formidable on se croirait
vraiment dans les avants de jeunes
américains dans les scènes d'action mais
c'est hyper spectaculaire donc en fait
on est pris de bout en bout bientôt ya
les vacances scolaires et c'est le sim
qui va cartonner avec la famille
formidable
regard
ah oui spéciales et cinéma jamais
question non moi j'étais fan de l'as
bram stocker et vous êtes les nouveaux
dans la même lignée mais si c'est vrai
avec la parodie clé référence cinéma
c'est vraiment bravo moi je suis fan je
suis comme cyril ce n'est pas une scène
cinéma th chiffres pour voir au film
mais on a eu à donner
des bonis palme et or vont en revanche
avec moi je suis fan depuis le début
annoncé dans les collections oui deux
dames élections et du tout une télé que
j'ai dans ma chance et non une chambre
et j'ai fait mes cascades ou où il ya
pas mal de doublure alors ouais
concernant et j'en ai fait certaines au
début du film à moi je descendais
escaliers
[Rires]
et envie de leur est conseillé aux gens
tombent j'ai envie de me faire le porte
parole d'elodie qui doit nous regarder
en rognant brasser l'eau n'a quant à
elle est en fait en promo à l'habitude
de sortir un dossier sur philippe sur ce
film c'est à dire que dans la
bande-annonce combattons voilà
en fait quand dans la bande annonce en
fait il a la tête en bas à la spiderman
et on voit en fait un moment ses fesses
oui mais ce ne sont pas ces faits n'ont
end ou bien faire un casting de fait
c'est
vrai je vais vous prouver
[Rires]
j'ai tendance à muscler le haut mais pas
trop le bat donc pour les bières du film